PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Welcome
to Get Cooking in Cloud,
where we share the best recipes
to apply in your cloud kitchen.
I'm Priyanka and
in this episode,
I am pleased to
welcome back Jen Person
to talk about another mobile
app backend service solution.
[THEME MUSIC]
Hello, Jen, welcome to
Get Cooking in Cloud.
JEN PERSON: Thanks, Priyanka.
I'm super excited to
share today's solution.
I think it's a real winner.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Well, so far you've
shown us some really
great recipes.
We've looked at some
architectures using Firebase,
and then another one using
Firebase and App Engine
standard.
And then yet another one
using Firebase and App Engine
flexible environment.
So we're all wondering what
are we cooking up today?
JEN PERSON: Well, the
ingredients for today's recipe
are the App Engine
standard environment
and the Endpoints frameworks.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Oh, yes.
I know that Endpoints
framework for the App Engine
standard environment generates
APIs, client libraries,
and discovery documentation
for an App Engine app.
JEN PERSON: Exactly.
This means you don't have
to write wrappers to handle
communication with App Engine.
And with the client libraries
generated by Endpoints,
you can make direct API
calls from your mobile app.
Using Endpoints with
App Engine gives you
an app platform that
monitors, updates, and scales
the hosting environment.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
What sort of apps
might not be a
great fit for this?
JEN PERSON: Well, I don't
recommend this architecture
if your app requires automatic
real time data synchronization
across devices.
For those apps, you'll want to
see one of the solutions that
includes Firebase.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So,
in Priyanka's kitchen,
could you help me understand
this with an example?
JEN PERSON: Well,
remember when we
talked about updating
player scores and rankings?
Since all client devices
needed the updated scores,
one of our previous
solutions using Firebase
is better for that use case.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So, what
are some of the other apps that
are not a great fit?
JEN PERSON: So, if you're
backend services require custom
servers or third
party libraries,
you'll want to look at
a solution with Firebase
an App Engine
flexible environments.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Ah.
Like for example, if I needed
custom payment processing
server to process payments
in Priyanka's Kitchen app,
then that payment
processing server can
be on App Engine flexible
environment integrating
with Firebase, right?
JEN PERSON: Exactly.
And finally, if your
systems don't support SSL,
you'll want to choose
another solution,
because SSL is
required by Endpoints.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: And if App
Engine with Endpoints sounds
like a good solution
for developers,
then how can they find out more?
JEN PERSON: Linked
below is a set
of getting started
tutorials that
show how to build the
Hello Endpoints sample app.
This sample lets you
send simple messages.
The backend service is
implemented on App Engine
and exposed to the mobile
app with Endpoints.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Awesome.
Well, if your use case requires
making direct API calls
from the mobile
app, then it's worth
checking out cloud Endpoints
and try this recipe.
That's all for today on
Get Cooking in Cloud.
Jen, thank you so
much for being here.
JEN PERSON:
Absolutely, it was fun.
And if you'd like to know
more about today's recipe,
you can check out the Endpoints
with the App Engine guides
and reference docs.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Join us next time
to see what you're cooking up.
If you liked this video, then
check out the other episodes
in the series.
And don't forget to
subscribe to our channel
so you can be notified
about new episodes of Get
Cooking in Cloud, as well
as other great Google cloud
content.
[MUSIC]